[Music]
I'm playing a manager and basically it's
based off of my manager a lot of the
story and basing it on your real life
man I realized manager who you know and
you know we all know in the business and
we all love sandy Wernick and he's right
over there there's a shot of blue okay
so that's that's mussolini after he
wrote a yeah order for that he didn't
take another shot of him that's all
right
yeah Danny you got on twice now only
charge him 12% yeah so how does it work
yeah you you're gonna do an impression
of saying yes a little bit but it's a
little like his attitude and stuff but
okay so anyways
smiley asked me if I had any good sandy
stories for real smiley the guy who
produced your sake yes yes your your man
right yeah what we fired but okay he
didn't come back but he just comes back
for you alright so anyways is a true
story and I guess I'll share it with you
because Frankie told me took this gives
us the essence of who's sandy where is
sandy Warnock I love him more than
anything but okay so either this is a
true story so he keeps telling me I
should read a script this is maybe 15
years ago or something he kept saying I
read this script you again I love it
and I okay man and then he'd say you got
to read it it's a good one and I say you
got it I'll do that and then like a
couple of weeks later you read Dan
script like I know not yet I'm gonna get
to that he goes it's your winter tiger I
don't read it I promise you and he's
like yeah you're gonna liked it so uh
something like three weeks later you get
two dead skipper I gotta get to that
you're right man he's like I'm not
steering you're wrong it's a doozy
you're gonna love it you just Charlotte
it's ready to go so that's all right
sandy I'll get to that so a month goes
by is like you gotta read that script
it's like absolutely I gotta get the
abyssal so then I'm starting to feel
guilty like it's too bad
it's Jerry chits it's a one-of-a-kind so
anyways I I'm not good at reading that's
the problem so that's why I was delaying
so much I got so much dyslexia going on
just like I can't please don't make me
read but out so I read the script and I
hated it and I hated it so much right
out the gate I was like my god I've seen
this like 2,000 times already these Joe
what the hell is he talking about but
I'm struggling to read it anyways
because of the dyslexia yeah so anyways
I finished the whole damn thing and I'm
stewing angry yeah still didn't like it
hey you hated it hated it more than a so
I I call him up and I'm in a bad mood
and it and he goes how long and I go hey
man you go did you read that screen and
I go I did man and it goes what you
think
and just at that moment I had to I had
to fart so so it was perfect time
perfect timing you and I hey guys what'd
he think and I got oh here's what I
thought and I put I put them we're
guessing ahead yeah I put the phone
there and blast that one of the loudest
parts I've ever had in my life so so
that I give back on the phone and it's
quiet not here did you fart and I go and
I got embarrassed cuz I love and I go uh
uh he goes dad you and I go yeah yeah I
farted he goes anyways what else she's
out you can sorry I got pretty goes on a
movie thank you for listening sandy
you